this is my twenty first cop I've been to
every single one I didn't want to miss
it this is the big one I come to the
negotiations in order to support the
negotiators from some of the poorest
countries they were here as a group of
the least about countries the vulnerable
countries including the least developed
countries but many other bubble
countries together have made a very
clear demand and that is what the
long-term goal coming out of the Paris
agreement is at the moment the agreed
global temperature rise is to degrees
the vulnerable countries feel that that
is not a viable
global goal to have because many many
poor people in the poor countries will
not
managed the doctor
so the demand is for a one and a half
degree global goal temperature
realizing is very difficult to do but
also saying that it's not impossible
there's enough money to do it there
but we have another two weeks to
generate that political
whatever we agree in Paris is not going
to affect what's going to happen to the
atmosphere in our lifetimes we are
negotiating what we want to leave behind
for our children and grandchildren here
plus the next 20 years of climate change
is already locked into the atmosphere if
the global leaders of planet Earth 200
countries on planet earth represent of
seven million people make the wrong
decisions then we'll be leaving the
planet that is much much worse
then we had heard it from our parents